I think it's the greatest gift that a
woman can ever have
I mean to be a mother to see this child
come out of you and then to see it grow
and to turn into a beautiful person it
means everything to me
celebrating a Mother's Day with Nicole
Murphy and she weighed in on what it's
like to be almost 50 and looking at this
good cannot believe I'm going to be
unbelievable I remember I got a now
think about planning to party oh my god
but I just remember as a kid looking at
people who are like turning 50 or you
know and they're 40 thumbs like they're
oh I would say it this is not what we
think of when we think of 50 no we had
to change it I had to change it you know
it's 40 year olds you know we got to
keep it together you keep it right Oh
first of all you gotta love yourself
second of all don't let fear hold you
back and third I would say exercise
you're not shy about showing off some
skin sexing it up on Instagram okay I'm
just letting you know it's not over
Oh looking like this are we looking for
love I'm still looking what you're
looking for I'm looking for somebody
who's got this stuff together who's
smart who likes to have fun like to
travel and he's got to be somewhat good
look at our nice body at least in a
decent body they don't have to be all
that but they can be decent
you